this is wrecking you you know what they  want they want you sitting  in a hotel room you're in vegas get  outside you want to go meet somebody you  want to have some fun  go walk up to somebody strike up a  conversation go out dancing take someone  to dinner get some heat going on  make it happen  no  they want you sitting in your hotel room  like an overgrown baby afraid of  rejection afraid of the world outside  it's scary  they want you watching  addicted to pornography that's totally  impossible for people to recreate in  real life that that sets  the bar here for weirdness and craziness  so when you go to actually have sex with  a real live woman you're bored  right  and they want you paying for it because  it's it's constant cash flow the more of  a vegetable you are the more money they  make